[eerie music]
♪ ♪
- COULD BE WORSE.
- NOT THAT BAD.
- FOR ME,
IT'S ALL ABOUT PERSPECTIVE.
- IT'S WHAT YOU MAKE
OF IT.
- LOOK, CAN I TELL YOU
SOMETHING?
ALL THINGS CONSIDERED,
I'M ACTUALLY KIND OF COMFORTABLE
RIGHT NOW.
THANK GOD FOR SHOCK.
- I CAN BE THE KIND OF PRISONER
I WANT TO BE.
- WE'RE STILL ALIVE.
- THANK YOU. RIGHT?
- MM-HMM.
- JUST TWO...
INJURED BUDDIES.
- YES, YEAH, MM-HMM.
- HAVING A FRIENDLY CONVO
WHILE WE'RE WAITING
TO GET TORTURED AGAIN.
- AND, YOU KNOW,
THERE'S A KIND OF A POSITIVE
IN HAVING NO OPTIONS.
- YES.
- BECAUSE, YOU KNOW,
WE'RE NOT EVEN GONNA TRY
TO ESCAPE
'CAUSE WE KNOW WE'D FAIL.
- YES.
TELL YOU ANOTHER THING.
DON'T MISS THE ARM.
- REALLY?
- FIRST OF ALL, LEFTY.
OKAY? SO THIS THING
PRETTY MUCH GOT IN THE WAY.
- HA.
- KEEP IT, BUDDY!
[metal screeches]
- YOU FOOLS,
BLATHERING AWAY!
[chuckles]
YOUR SUFFERING
HAS ONLY JUST BEGUN.
- WOW.
THAT IS
A PERFECT SUMMATION
OF THE HUMAN CONDITION.
AND ONCE
YOU'VE EMBRACED THAT,
YOU CAN DO ANYTHING.
- BINGO.
- [screams]
NO ONE HAS EVER SUFFERED
AS YOU WILL!
HAH HAH HAH HAH HAH HAH!
- YOU LOVE YOUR WORK,
AND THAT KIND
OF A POSITIVE ATTITUDE,
QUITE FRANKLY,
IT'S CONTAGIOUS.
- IT IS.
- WELL, WE'LL SEE
HOW POSITIVE YOU'RE FEELING
AFTER I COVER YOUR BODY
IN GASOLINE
AND SET YOU ON FIRE!
- YOU KNOW WHAT, IT'S AMAZING
THAT YOU WOULD SAY THAT,
'CAUSE I WAS JUST THINKING
IT'S GETTING A LITTLE CHILLY
IN HERE.
- MM-HMM.
- THANKS SO MUCH, MAN.
- DAMN IT!
[screams]
- WHAT A DRAMATIC
AND FASCINATING MAN.
- I THINK WE OWE HIM
BIG TIME.
- AS DO I.
- REALLY.
I MEAN, ALL THIS TIME
AWAY FROM MY COMPUTER,
MY PHONE, MY WORK,
IT'S JUST--
I FEEL UNPLUGGED.
- YES, YES. OH.
- OH.
[rat squeaking]
both: AWW.
- CIRCLE OF LIFE.
- NANTS INGONYAMA.
- AND I CAN'T REALLY FEEL
ANYTHING ANYWAY,
SO YOU HELP YOURSELF, BUDDY.
[saw whirring]
- OH, WHAT DO YOU GOT THERE?
- DO YOU SEE THIS?
THIS IS WHAT I'M GOING TO USE
TO CUT OFF YOUR LEGS!
- FINALLY!
- THAT'S A GREAT SAW.
I'M A HOME IMPROVEMENT GUY,
AND I KNOW MY SAWS,
AND I GOTTA TELL YOU,
IF YOU'RE CUTTING OFF LEGS,
THAT IS THE WAY TO GO.
- THAT'S THE ONE?
- THAT IS DEFINITELY THE ONE.
GOOD ON YA.
- WHY ARE YOU DOING THIS TO ME?
YOU'RE MAKING ME CRAZY!
- WHOA, WHOA, WHOA, WHOA.
SOMEBODY NEEDS A DAY OFF.
- WE, OF ALL PEOPLE,
SHOULD KNOW HOW HARD HE WORKS.
- MM-HMM, MM-HMM.
- [giggling, sobbing]
MAKE THEM STOP!
THIS IS TORTURE!
NOOOO!